so we have the graph of y is equal to h
of x right over here and they ask us
does the intermediate value theorem
apply to h over the closed interval from
negative one to four so the closed
interval from negative 1 to
4 right over here
so let's we could first remind ourselves
what is the intermediate value theorem
although you don't have to even know
what the theorem is actually saying you
just have to remember that the
intermediate value theorem only applies
over closed intervals where the function
is continuous so you just have to say
you might be tempted to say wait this
function has a point of discontinuity
but this is outside of that interval the
interval we care about at negative 1
this is the value of
h of x and then at 4 this is the value
of h of x and you can see over that
entire interval right over here the
function is continuous so first i would
definitely say it meets the continuity
requirement it's continuous over this
closed interval and so i would say yes
it does the intermediate value theorem
does apply and since it does apply i
will be able to say that by the
intermediate value theorem because we
are continuous over this closed interval
the function in this case h of x will
take on every value between h of
negative 1 and h of 4 including those
values and so h of negative 1 eyeballing
it looks like it's negative 3 and h of 4
looks like it's 0. so we know by the
intermediate value theorem that we take
on every value between negative 3 and 0.
and you can even see that right over
here it actually does take on every one
of those values in this part
in
this part
of
the curve
right over there let's do another
example
so here we say we're asked does the
extreme value theorem apply to g over
the closed interval from zero to five
so once again before we even think about
what the extreme value theorem
says we just remember that just like the
intermediate value theorem it only
applies over closed intervals where the
function is continuous over the entire
interval so let's see is our function
continuous on the closed interval from 0
to 5. so from 0
to 5.
no we clearly have a discontinuity right
over here at x is equal to 3. so first
of all we would say no and so the x we
can't say that over this closed interval
that we have a well-defined maximum or
minimum value and this is actually very
clear over here that you don't have a
well-defined maximum value we approach
infinity over there and we approach
negative infinity over there and so
extreme value theorem does not apply if
instead it had offered us a closed
interval where we were continuous say
they said between
negative 2 and
0 let's say it's that interval let me
use a different color say it was between
negative 2 and 0 then the extreme value
theorem would apply where you would say
okay
over this interval the function has a
well-defined minimum value and a maximum
value and in this case it would actually
the maximum would happen at the right
bound and the minimum value happens at
the left bound but for this case the
closed interval the one that we started
with definitely is not continuous so we
do not we would not say that the extreme
value theorem applies
let's do one more example
does the extreme value theorem apply to
f over the interval from negative 5 to
negative 2.
so once again let's just look at the
interval we're going from negative 5
going from negative 5 to negative 2. so
this is our function over that interval
from negative 5 from x equals negative 5
to x equals negative 2.
and even though there is a discontinuity
in this graph that we see it's sitting
outside of the interval we only care
about what's happening inside of the
interval and there we actually are
continuous we're continuous over this
closed interval and so because of that
we know that the extreme value theorem
would apply that there is a well-defined
minimum and maximum value over the
interval and you can see that the
maximum value here happens when at f of
negative 2 looks like it's around
negative 3.5 or so or negative 3.6 and
the minimum value over this interval
looks like it happens at
f of negative 5. it looks like it's
pretty close to
negative 4 because it looks like we're
just increasing over this entire
interval but the important thing here is
to recognize continuity continuity does
not have to apply to the entire function
or over its entire domain it just has to
be true over the closed interval that we
are trying to apply these theorems to